ma avete di fronte a voi un prodotto in
via di estinzione
io ho 54 anni mi chiamo paolo bonolis
sono 35 anni che lavoro nelle reazione
nella scrittura e nella conduzione di
programmi televisivi
io non ho scoperte da mostrarvi non ho
una conoscenza così profonda da poter
condividere con voi o da poter di
insegnare e giustamente voi farete la
domanda allora che vuoi
sono qui perché mi hanno invitato e io
cinque anni fa sei anni fa circa
conobbi per la prima volta grazie a uno
degli autori che lavora insieme a me il
mondo di ted hanno trovato bellissimo
l'ho trovata una tra le cose più belle
che ho visto negli ultimi vent'anni è
una splendida osservatorio osservatorio
della della conoscenza e della
condivisione
e allora quando mi hanno detto vuoi
partecipare ho detto va bene partecipo
però mi sono anche domandato di como che
ti dico a questi giustamente non avendo
scoperte non avendo conoscenze provo a
condividere con voi un pensiero un
pensiero che mi è venuto in mente quando
mi hanno chiesto di venire qui e il
pensiero a venuto in mente ricordando
quando da ragazzo è ancora oggi leggevo
libri di fantascienza
ne ho letti tantissimi tantissimi
tantissimi e alcuni racconti alcuni
libri di fantascienza e mi hanno colpito
più di altri tanto che questo che vi sto
brevemente per raccontare
mi è rimasto impresso dopo quasi 40 anni
che l'avevo letto è un libro scritto da
un io non sono analogico da scritto da
un certo fredrik è un racconto breve del
1954 ed è un racconto che racconta una
storia buffa frana piccola piccola
piccola
un gruppo di scienziati in quell'anno
nel 1954 decide di costruire un computer
e computer lo sapete insomma se avete
visto il film limitation game potete
capire di che si tratta i computer a
quei tempi a giganteschi monolite una
sorta di ddt di vergine di norimberga
dove invece che degli spuntoni dentro
c'erano transistor valvole queste cose
qua e costruiscono questo coso
gigantesco al quale pongono la domanda
delle domande dio esiste
dopo pochi secondi
esce la risposta potenza di calcolo
insufficiente cavoli giusto dicono gli
scienziati la domanda è così enorme e
allora costruiscono un altro computer
altrettanto grande e stiamo parlando di
un romanzo del 1954 connettono questi
due computer per rendere più potente la
potenza giusto appunto della ricerca del
computer
fondamentalmente nel 1954 questo tal
fredrik aveva costruito nella sua
immaginazione la prima maglia da quella
che sarebbe stata poi la rete alla
domanda dio esiste la risposta è sempre
la stessa potenza di calcolo
insufficiente questo manipolo di
scienziati ha deciso di non darsi per
vinti e continuano a costruire un
computer dietro l'altro e connettere un
computer all'altro computer all'altro
creando una sorta di cittadina di
computer giganteschi connessi tra di
loro ma alla domanda dio esiste la
risposta è sempre la stessa potenza di
calcolo insufficiente
passano i decenni passano i secoli la
tecnologia cresce cresce in maniera
smisurata al punto che i computer ormai
sono sofisticatissimi talmente
sofisticati talmente connessi tra loro
che riescono ad auto rigenerarsi
ma alla domanda preimpostata dio esiste
la risposta è sempre la stessa potenza
di calcolo insufficiente questa storia
va un po per le lunghe l'umanità
scompare non c'è più nessuno ci sono
solamente questo infinito esercito di
computer che continua a riprodursi
diventando gigantesco e finché un giorno
del silenzio dell'universo alla domanda
preimpostata dio esiste
esce la risposta
adesso sì il racconto breve si intitola
di hands già scritto da questo tal
fredrik di cui non ricordo il cognome ma
perché vi ho fatto questo racconto
perché mi è venuto in mente questo
racconto perché secondo me c'è
un'analogia già nascosta nel racconto
che prova a condividere un mio pensiero
potete ricusarlo potete fischiarlo
potete rifiutarlo completamente però mi
è venuta in mente così io non ho come lo
chiamano gli americani igor giger click
che cosa li che se fa così sono
analogico ma funziona e tu lo puoi
portare dappertutto
l'analogia l'analogia è tra dio e il
computer dio qualunque dio vogliate voi
mettetela come volete però
effettivamente perché fin dagli albori
dell'umanità
l'uomo ha confezionato l'idea la
proiezione di dio e perché oggi c'è
questa pulsione fortissima nei confronti
della rete del computer da tecnologia
che permette tutto ciò perché secondo me
sì a dio che il computer ci danno una
opportunità quella di scavallare le
colonne d'ercole della nostra esistenza
terrena ciò che ci chiede qui bloccate
un pò afflitti lo spazio e il tempo
grazie alla velocità del computer e alle
sue possibilità non ci possiamo muovere
velocemente tra lo spazio e il tempo nel
mondo virtuale
certo per dio bisogna aspettare un po
bisogna aspettare di tirare le cuoia
siamo in una vita ultraterrena ma bene o
male la zuppe la stessa fondamentalmente
noi attraverso la figura di dio e la
figura del computer
cerchiamo di vincere questa eterna
battaglia della nostra vita superare
queste barriere lo spazio e il tempo ed
è un processo logico di voler cercare di
affrontare la problematica però la
storia è un processo di apprendimento
quanto un processo di dimenticanze
allora io che non sono un digitale sono
un analogico vi offro una riflessione
occhio alla penna non so come lo
tradurranno se poi questa cosa andrà in
tutto il mondo dico ma attenzione perché
il computer la velocità la virtualità
può creare degli smarrimenti
quali sono questi smarrimenti beh
insomma alcuni sono abbastanza evidenti
l'atrofizzazione ad esempio della
memoria
noi deleghiamo tutto a qualcuno che si
ricorda tutto per noi
e poi noi ci dimentichiamo tutto quello
che invece potremmo serenamente
ricordare con la nostra mente tenendola
allenata ok e questo è un punto 1 la
conoscenza primo sentito l'affascinante
chiacchierata del nostro amico greco no
la conoscenza si è importante ma la
conoscenza attraverso la rete è una
conoscenza indotta non è una conoscenza
dedotta è una conoscenza un po
differente dove sei mesi vengono ad
abbattere i nostri i nostri cinque sensi
la possibilità di riconoscere buttandoci
addosso l'esperienza del raggiungere
l'obiettivo e questo ci porta al terzo
punto da dividere in due maniere un e il
disagio
qual è il disagio a disagio che
potrebbero avvertire i nativi digitali
il disagio di dover di poter vivere
nella virtualità in assenza di spazio e
di tempo o quantomeno talmente limitato
da apparire assente e ritrovarsi poi
nella realtà dove invece lo spazio e il
tempo sono belli pesanti da affrontare
se li accetti civili
se li dimentichi diventano dei bastioni
insormontabili che renderebbero
probabilmente alla nostra vita piuttosto
disagiata ma lo stesso tipo di disagio
lo si può rintracciare anche in un altro
modo e sotterraneo e su cutaneo è la
perdita del valore perché cos'è che
conferisce valore ad una cosa la fatica
di poterla raggiungere la fatica
impiegata per ottenerla nello spazio noi
facciamo fatica a raggiungere un posto
attraverso questa fatica raccogliamo un
mare di informazioni le facciamo nostre
quando questo posto finalmente viene
raggiunto caspita se ce lo ricordiamo
perché tutta la fatica investita che ce
lo rende prezioso e nel tempo nel tempo
e la stessa cosa sarebbe un problema
smarrire il senso dell'attesa la
velocità repentina di poter ottenere una
cosa ci toglie l'attesa in assenza di
attesa il desiderato una volta ottenuto
non ha quel valore che altrimenti
avrebbe avuto se lo avessimo dovuto
aspettare beh insomma può sembrare il
minimo sindacale quello che mi è venuto
in mente da potervi raccontare qui ve
l'ho detto e sono stato felice di
poterlo condividere poi trattate voi
l'argomento come riterrete più opportuno
ve l'ho detto tranne voi cioè quello che
viene chiamato digital divided no io
sono analogico voi siete digitali vi ho
parlato come se fossi un padre sono il
più vecchio credo tra quelli che hanno
parlato qui ho 54 anni dico però sono
contento di averlo fatto anche se un po
mi sento sconfitto in questo pensiero
perché mirabilmente un grande sociologo
di debord ha detto l'uomo assomiglia ai
suoi tempi più di quanto assomigli a suo
padre
grazie